got the ATL yeah NYC but hopefully we
get a KC here soon I'll have those on
for sure I picked out everything this is
the first time to either of us of
everyone it's cool I mean just to have
your own place our own house where we
can we can grow into and so this is
definitely a big step in our life we
renovated a lot of the house the last
thing was the shoe room has been
something that I've wanted for the last
six seven years at least you have the
vision the one it's like all the way
broken down and it's gutted like that
it's hard to see it I mean it's crazy
what people can do with a space
I'm extremely pumped I've been hyping it
up for weeks all of his shoes have been
all over the house and I was trying to
make my own shoe closet and it didn't
work out so well so you hear now y'all
should have seen these the shelves that
she put into both the wall they lasted
about two and a half weeks okay we're
here hey Google it's show time
you got it Oh
[Applause]
guess what I'm talking about right there
dude this is awesome
that the favorite shoes right here I
like it I like you my babies our glasses
look good how do you even aim well you
don't have enough room I thought you
lose the value of some of your shoes
some of the shoes that people worn once
you forget about you don't see them so I
wanted that shearing the highlight that
like what they kind of have that like
pokey everybody's kind of into now but
these I feel like still have a little
bit of like the sports tune these are my
favorite these are my babies these
triple black 750s they're big but the
same time you can wear them with
anything I'm like scared to mess up any
shoes you know I'm saying like they look
so good like this good again I'm at a
hundred and eighty pairs is what I got
it down to I feel like that's enough I
can wear each one of them like twice a
year got the babes babes back-to-back
right here I like these shoes a lot
these future crafts see I still have my
sea lions don't worry
then I got my my Game of Thrones Night
Watch ultra boost some big game of
Thrones guy you represent for Jon Snow I
like the fur L&M bees give you like a
sneaker feel so uncomfortable but at the
same time they still have some swaggy
tone these were some my first shoot with
adidas so I like these a lot
they're the life those awesome the light
here the light there like it just it
really shows the shoe you know what I
mean and then the glasses even takes it
to a new level makes me want to like go
out and buy more if I come into a game
you might send me one of these at one
time these are like what the visors are
on the football field I'll let you wear
these when I like throw sometimes you
kind of get myself used to it these are
my like snowboarders ones dude you hate
all you want but I'm into the big shades
these are like my go-to it's big makes a
statement at the same time it's subtle
these are the game days I got a little
glittery in there and I wore these a
couple games last year you know I gotta
have some swag out there when I'm hoop
it's not a lot of play basketball
anymore y'all probably saw that but when
I did play I had all all the different
shoes the camera is definitely the most
important
I mean it's showing all the most
valuable things in the house my brother
comes and stays with us and I know he'll
try to be in my shoe closet so I got to
make sure when I have
the camera that I can look to make sure
all my shoes are still here